no no Mom no Mom it wasn't the actual
devil no they were just dressed as the
devil mom who are you that you don't
want to watch the Grammys seems like Ben
Affleck that's who I'm ready I'm excited
about it yeah JLo looked way more
excited about the Grammys on Sunday and
we're hearing it's because Ben was
feeling tired with a source selling E.T
they both have been very busy and the
actor wasn't his usual self but he still
wanted to support Jin who presented the
award for best pop vocal album Harry's
house Harry Styles
[Applause]
[Music]
if someone says why would you watch the
Grammys I caught on to that why wouldn't
you you don't see Harry Styles this
comes after Ben went viral on social
media with claims he looked super
serious and bored even though he and Jen
had front row seats at the biggest night
in music no no Mom no Mom it wasn't the
actual devil no they were just dressed
as the devil mom they don't yeah no I
have to go yeah yeah you did warn me
about Hollywood one person joked quote
however bad of a day you're having I
promise you're not as miserable as Ben
Affleck at the Grammys right now another
tweeted quote Ben Affleck is every
husband dragged to a work thing by his
wife or like give it away but it has a
very good ending yeah sure does with our
source revealing the newlyweds still
made it a fun date night adding that Jen
understands her husband's more of a
homebody quote Jennifer is appreciative
of Ben's support whether it's while
they're out and about or just hanging at
home and that Echoes a dinner for a
moment from this time last last year
when Ben stepped out to celebrate his
love at the Marry Me premiere it's a
great date night we're super happy
um what can I tell you we're just having
a good time
[Music]